hi reg well good morning and happy
belated turkey day Theodore and my dad
what did you do for thanksgiving I went
to the desert I was in la quinta with
the family doing a little shredding on
my mountain bike and relaxing and having
a good time nice nice yeah and how was
your on you with family yes I was with a
lot of families too many fan good yes
but all the Thanksgiving is about it's
about being with a lot of family and
getting into those heated monopoly clue
trouble ooh no argument okay i'm sure
you all got into but your family's
competitive I know you and Cheryl are
but did you guys ever get into like is
it ever been heated in the in the Miller
household God thank you hitting me of
course they don't get us all together to
play a game of Numb monopoly Trump would
have nothing on the Miller family in
terms of uh you know putting hotels on
frickin boardwalk or and I know you're
all taking we were put we were putting
hotels everywhere we would have a lot of
business conflicts just like a trumpet
gonna have during his presidency you
were putting the hotels up in jail there
exactly little condo in the corner but
you and Cheryl like you guys would never
have an like sports did you know
arguments like that at Thanksgiving
would you know if you a lot of people
wanted to assume that we did because her
being a Trojan and me being a Bruin we
actually got along because I was the
biggest USC Trojan fan when Cheryl
played UCLA and I know the coaches the
women's coaches did not like that you
know they think you should be loyal and
you know to your school but blood is
much more thicker but that was the only
time that I ever ever cheered for a USC
trojan to win a game was when Cheryl was
wearing the wearing her colors versus
the Bruins but even football you didn't
admire USC football look um UCLA was not
that good
no we were not that good and I told
Cheryl we're not a football school they
okay no we are not okay MBP on an
average team or better than average team
if russell westbrook averages a
triple-double you see the MVP yes and I
said this even before the season if they
get to 45 to 47 wins and he has the kind
of season that I was assuming what she's
having right now that he would have I
didn't think he was going to be
averaging a triple-double through 19
games but if these kind of numbers
absolutely and i also had Billy Donovan
as coach of the year if they want 45 to
47 games because with the loss of Kevin
Durant you know it was going to be a
changing of the guard so to speak for
Russell Westbrook and you know for Billy
Donovan and for both of those guys that
put up the numbers especially rust I
mean this is an unbelievable pace he's
been on so you know the magic number for
me was 45 but if he's averaging close to
a triple-double absolutely he should he
be the MVP what about Anthony Davis if
he has a similar record but he won't I
don't think they'll get to 40 wins and
you know it we've seen this in baseball
I believe a radwan the nvp on the last
play Seattle team am i right about that
yeah that no it was with Texas I think
weren't active Titus right and they you
know they were in last place and you won
the MVP so it you know it's been done
before obviously in other sports it's
been a while since it's been done in the
NBA we usually like to regard winners
teams guys that have been on winning
teams with the with the MVP but if
Westbrook continues to put up these
numbers at like I love the numbers of
Anthony Davis is putting up he just does
have a real supporting cast you know I I
see 35 to 38 wins for New Orleans but I
definitely can see the fender you know
45 plus wins in Russell winning that MVP
Reggie will be on the call for the
Rockets at the Warriors that will be
thursday night at ten thirty eastern on
tnt but then there
lot of other great candidates uh you
know you mentioned Houston who only be
calling on Thursday what James Harden is
doing you know moving to that point
guard position and you know what let's
stop calling him a point guard let's
just call him a player he's a baller no
he said rail Reggie's appoints guard by
by title but he's a baller last year he
was a shooting guard and this year no
but I'm combining the two I'm combine
he's not a point guard he's a point
guard so he scores and he need
distributes he doesn't he does it all
yeah you would put him in the MVP I
would put quite linen in there LeBron
James you mentioned Anthony Davis a lot
of there's a lot of guys that have
strong early season candidates for MVP
who would you rather have James Harden
Russell Westbrook and it doesn't matter
who my supporting cast in know if I was
starting to draft and those two guys are
the first one 1 & 2 yes Russell Russell
man this dude I that demeanor man Oh
baby no I love it yes I love Russell
Westbrook man and i'm not saying because
he's a Bruin but man this kid don't care
you don't care about anyone but his
family and his teammate can he have
mentorship on his shoulder for 82 games
I hope Billy Donovan in them try to find
rest for him because he just played
back-to-back minutes of 38 and 41
minutes and that is way too much this
early in the season so I hope they find
ways to rest him but it it's different
now because before when you had kevin
durand you could play off one another
and guys could take breaks and rest
Russell doesn't have that luxury anymore
because he has to do so much he's Reggie
Miller he's got rockets and the Warriors
on Thursday night if I said harden or
Kevin Durant Kevin Durant harden or
Steph come on down this road with you as
you have the game coming up thursday
night
and it does not matter whose according
capitulo you're starting matter you're
starting your team and you got hardened
or Steph Curry and Reggie Miller is on
the clock with the first pick and Reggie
your pic is and knowing what I know now
yes I'm going still with that I'm not
trying to discount what James has done
and is doing because I think we were
going to see the type of play out of him
under the Mike D'Antoni system but he
has flipped the script and again in
early season candidate for MVP just for
the simple fact the passes he's making
were shots last year let's be honest he
was to me he was borderline the selfish
player last year I don't know it the
rift with Dwight Howard or the system he
just didn't care this year he's showing
that he's care and he has incorporated
his teammates along the way and i love
it i love the way he's playing last time
i talked to Tom Herman he left Houston
to take the Texas job and I don't know
did you have the same coach all four
years at UCLA no my first year was Larry
farmer and my last three was Walt hazard
okay cuz I you know that whole thing of
a coach looking at a nother job and you
know that you you couldn't transfer
without sitting out but a coach can take
a job so you didn't experience that no
but this goes back to my whole NCAA
thing and double standards because why
can't a player do the same thing and
coach does especially the coaches are
getting millions of dollars from shoe
companies they can change venues and get
to work right away but a student-athlete
quote student athletes have to sit out a
particular year I just don't understand
at times the hypocrisy that the NCAA has
in terms of its student-athletes and its
policies a couple of the things NBA wise
Mark Cuban says the Mavericks are not
tanking even though they're not playing
very well do you believe in well i know
i'll be there taking Dirk has been hurt
at a stress of a time Deron Williams has
not been healthy and I think if you're
Rick Carlisle you
look at the big picture you see the
landscape of the Western Conference and
he wants his guys to be healthy you know
after the new year so tanking for what
because I look at the college game I
there's not one Ben Simmons overall
number one pick coming out this year so
I don't know exactly what you're taking
for I think more so Rick Carlisle and
Cuban want his guys to be healthy yeah I
just looking at the same thing when
you're saying all right if we're tanking
who are we taking for and I we haven't
seen enough college basketball yet this
year where you say okay that guy is
going to be the number one overall pick
and even then if it's a number one
overall pick it doesn't mean it's a
LeBron you're going to get it I mean
once the last time a team with the worst
work record have gotten the overall
number one pick true I don't know me
that well so yeah absolutely um anything
else on your mind that I need to uh
bring the nation's attention to well
how'd my man fritzy with the double
hernia is he back now to that you know I
talk to Paulie but it's been a while so
they spoke to my man Fritzi is he doing
okay how long would you how long would
you be on for a double hernia surgery
maybe couple days it's so I got a high
tolerance for pain are you telling me
frisky is like milking it come on pretty
man don't be one of those guys to which
tomorrow we have two weeks tomorrow two
weeks yeah oh come on man I thought my
dad has were tougher than there no no
there are you kidding me now another
what Paulie we just all so don't lump us
in Ellie's all of us haven't gone
anywhere well mclovin is made milk in
the high ankle sprain for two years now
yeah what I mean with it this is this is
unacceptable danettes I thought y'all
were better than this I thought I
trained you guys better than it just uh
what mclovin it is to hernias Dan to be
fair but it's one surgery right I don't
reg it is to hernias and one surgery
count as one is its double hernia
surgery we know what goes into the
recovery of a double hernia like what is
the time what like what does he have to
do to get on a walker I me what is the
you know did you have to go for therapy
I have no ideas bedre I know that blac
Chyna just had a baby with Rob
Kardashian and she's already out looking
great so I you know just sayin reg
pretty if you're listening which we know
you are come on buck up man you're
making all of us danette look bad all of
us well try to stir it up at Golden
State rockets at Golden State thursday
night at ten thirty East were you really
if you didn't have that game now be
honest with if you didn't have that game
and I asked you James Harden and Steph
Curry would you have would you have said
James Harden what way home why do you
think this is because because i'm doing
the game i gotta go with Steph Curry
everyone yeah what I'm going to see both
of them there's no there's no punk in my
game they're not going to tell that to I
would tell that to a James Harden you
would I'm not outweigh hon I'm not alone
in my thinking I'm sure those tortillas
people would go with them but if you
went with James Harden and Steph came up
to you and said reg what's the deal you
went with James over me they would
probably be a little disappointed but I
mean it is what it is a lot of guys are
upset and certain things when we make
predictions all that but that's it it's
my opinion doesn't mean anything that's
just my opinion yeah that's when I sat
down with Mark Jackson we had dinner
with Patrick Ewing and mark set me up
and he goes tell Patrick who you would
take over him and I'm sitting at dinner
with Patrick like oh well I'd take
hakeem olajuwon over you and Patrick
goes all right I don't blame you and
then that was it but it was awkward
awkward but where Mark Jackson tried to
get me with that I wasn't afraid of
Patrick Ewing a drooling all what I was
afraid of Patrick I was afraid of
Patrick really I was probably no he's
just a jump shooting center come on no
oh no he was more than that madhu was
more than that jumbo would scare you
more than patrick ewing finger wave that
did kind of soon-ish it resentment and
my final you never went to you weren't
going to the whom you that's not what
that's not your there you go
again go back first eight years look at
my free throw attempts I'm not just
shooting jump shots go back first eight
years just like a free throw attempts
I'm up there were calm alone just go
back if you want to you know be a little
historian okay the free thorium okay
right he's Reggie he'll be on the call
Thursday night golden state warriors in
the Rockets at ten thirty eastern on tnt
reg you're the best theater everybody
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience